this song is fantastic for a whole bunch
of reasons it feels like you've evolved
and it's just so much fun thank you you
know I I had an epiphany about a year
and a half ago that I really wanted an
opportunity to leave my comfort zone and
that that meant a lot of things that
meant that we meant that for the first
time in my life I wanted to to produce
it meant that I would write with
different people and and it meant that
no matter what I would do whatever was
best for the song and whatever's best
for the record that ego and all
self-doubt must be thrown aside and a
song like nobody but me that meant that
I felt what would take the song to the
next level was having Tarik Black
Thought writer from the roots and have
him do a freestyle and I know it was
hard for some people to digest because
they have a certain image or identity of
who Michael Buble is finding that it oh
listen I found I was I was threatened no
no no no no I mean I was there of course
I people people in my life in my
business in in different facets of
record companies or they listen they
never stopped me but I was told be
prepared that if you do this you're
going to lose a big part of your
audience and I kept saying how could
that be possible how is it possible I
never saw and I know I didn't understand
even what they meant I was like this is
this music comes from the birth of jazz
and it's so cohesive and it's so
perfectly black thought is this
wonderful thoughtful intelligent
well-spoken musician and respected
musician I liked so much and how could
this not work in perfect harmony how
could this be a problem but it just kind
of tells you about where people's
thoughts are with everything from I'm
sorry but from race 2 to 2 just what
what people are thinking right now and
how sensitive things are that they could
even think that there could be an issue
and then my whole thought was that if
there's a part of the audience that has
an issue with that then you know I'm
okay with them not being part of my
audience anymore and
I just love it I love the song I love
showing growth and the fact is I have
whole rest of record that is pure to my
soul in my heart and it's the standards
that 55 million people loved in the
first place so I haven't turned my back
on them and tried to turn into something
I'm not I just wanted to show growth I
think it's more of your opening your
heart and your mind to other things you
know turning your back on it
no no I mean um and what people out
there don't know and what again my son
weird is that one of the biggest
inspirations for this record was the
movie Straight Outta Compton and the NWA
I know this sounds so weird it was
always kind of a big part of my life
because my brother-in-law was such a fan
Massa fan and when my sister had her
first kid which was like our first baby
in the family you know my bank where my
mom and dad became a grandma for the
first time they named their first son
O'Shea and when people were like what
why did you name him O'Shea what's oh
[ __ ] what do you Scottish or something
and they were like no he's that's you
named after Ice Cube and so for me it
was just it was a well you know what
what that movie was awesome for me
because I'm not even talking about race
thought it's obviously so important I
got to see four guys creating an
environment in which they they really
loved each other and support each other
and they gave each other the strength to
tell a story that they needed that they
needed to tell and and I also I even
gained more respect for the genre of
music I really did for the for the
artfulness of it for the intelligence
behind it and I think I'd always liked
it but I didn't know why as much as I do
now and so it just it really gave me a
jolt my manager had seen it like three
times and he said to me once at night
you got to come you got to come you got
to come
it just really had a big impact on me it
inspired me and I basically this and
other things I just knew I walked I
walked but got home one night and I said
that's it I said I'm gonna go change a
lot of things gonna produce this gonna
write with different people gonna you
know show different side and and more
than anything I just thought it's time
you know you've earned the right to risk
to risk it you know for sure I think so
I don't think you